hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
striking metaphors in Plato's great work
the Phaedo is of the body as being
something like a prisons my depiction of
a prison here a prison cell for the Soul
and he's got this really interesting
account that doesn't just have the soul
of prisoned stuck within the material
body but has the soul playing a role
sort of collaborating with its own
imprisonment because it doesn't actually
understand how how I could get out of
this and making its condition worse and
then philosophy coming in and playing a
role a gradual goal in liberating the
soul from this so let's start out first
with this metaphor Socrates says and
this is probably the most stark
expression of platonic dualism and
against the body anywhere you're gonna
find and Plato's dialogues Socrates says
that the body is like a prison to the
soul so that the soul is stuck inside
and can only look through the bars
remember - he's in a prison cell at this
very time the soul can only look through
the bars
what's outside so that the body acts as
a kind of filter for reality and reality
is going to turn out to comprise two
different realms we're going to get to
that in just a moment but let's let's
think about this first so the metaphor
is that the body ends up filtering out
what the soul can actually perceive the
soul is stuck within it and it's a
helpless prisoner
it says bound hand and feet and again
remember Socrates was himself shortly
before this conversation bound in chains
and they're only releasing him so that
he can die so there's a lot of
interesting symbology going in here now
when we go a little bit further with us
you notice I've got this rather complex
diagram here the passage that we're
looking at Socrates tells his
interlocutors that the relationship
between the body and the soul is not
just this is prison relationship but
that the body gets used by the soul but
also contaminates the soul with
materiality so it's interesting because
the soul can actually take on the
characteristic of body
this is his his way of you know sort of
suggesting that some souls aren't ready
to move on right away into another state
of being after after death after
separation for the body because there's
so much of the body contaminating them
now
how does this happen Socrates has this
metaphor of rivets and you know think of
pegs or think of you could use other
things as well think of stitching in
terms of clothing or think of glue that
can binds things together the body the
body the soul are together while we're
in this life right the body relates
itself to the visible and material world
so the body is kind of a locus for
giving us the way to engage with this
this world that we see here you know
what we're filming right now
this chalkboard you know it's solid if I
want to write on this truck board it's
not my sole writing on the truck where
the soul is in some way directing the
body to do that so the body relates
itself to the visible material world
through action but also in large part
through the senses through hearing
through site through smell through touch
so you know the chalkboards here because
I'm touching it I can see it there it
makes a little wrapping sound right we
could do a whole bunch of experiments
this way the body also is the locus
where desires and fears of things in the
the larger material world occur so you
know in another place Socrates will say
it's because of the care of the body
that we pursue things that distract us
like wealth you know you need money
so that you can keep feeding your body
or so you can dress up in nice clothes
you know or warm clothes this is
actually great example this corduroy
jacket because it serves you know a
purpose as far as being a nice bourgeois
intellectual you know I put on your
corduroy jacket and your study and all
that that's sort of business but I also
like it myself because it's warm its
corduroy so it's great for for cool
weather but that's that's about the body
right the soul doesn't get cold the body
gets cold the body wants to be dressed
up the body needs all these sorts of
things there's desires and fears
associated with it and along with this
pleasures and pains and Socrates will
say every pleasure and every pain that
the body feels and which the soul then
experiences through the body is like a
rhythmic binding the two of them
together or you can think of it as sort
of like an entry point whereby
materiality comes more and more to
intrude upon to penetrate to occupy to
contaminate the soul with
with the essence of the body meanwhile
what the soul really ought to be doing
Socrates says is concerning itself with
what's really real what's not just
apparently real but what's really real
the unseen by the way the other word for
unseen ie nice in Greek Hades is what we
we translate it as is the unseen world
but we don't need to worry too much
about that but the unseen world of the
forms the realities that we can perceive
not through the body but only through
the mind or the soul
they're pure they're uniform and they're
divine this is where this is the realm
of the the gods or the God or God ship
or whatever you want to call it for
Plato and the soul can only do that by
breaking the connection with the body
and contemplating the divine dissociated
from the body and that you know there
could be certain pleasures and uses this
in other places the pleasures and pains
that that might come with this but
they're not gonna be the pleasures and
pains of the body they're not could be
plenty even pains of satisfying thirst
or hunger or sexual desire or even the
desire for honor or domination so he
talks here about here we go
the the role of philosophy what is
philosophy to do philosophy has to show
the soul first off that the soul is
actually collaborating with the body by
doing all these things in relation to
the the visible world and feeling
pleasures and pains the soul is
collaborating with the body in its own
imprisonment
so he says philosophy can see that the
imprisonment is affected by the
prisoners own active desire the soul
feels desire and it desires through the
body into the visible world
and it occupies itself with that so the
the designer makes the sole accessory to
its own confinement so philosophy
approaches the soul in this condition
and then it says look you know all this
stuff over here this is really real you
want to be turning your attention to
something over here this is very much
like the the allegory of the cave isn't
it that he talks about in the Republic
and then what with the this the the soul
finds out through philosophy is that
what it must do is refrain from using
the senses unless it needs to instead
it's supposed to collect and concentrate
upon itself and use its powers to grasp
what's in the unseen but intelligible
world and attribute no truth to anything
which it views indirectly as being
subject to variation because such
objects are sensible and visible but
only to what the soul sees as
intelligible so the soul of the true
philosopher is going to realize that
what we need to do is actually free
ourselves of all of this stuff over here
and concentrate just on this that's how
we liberate ourselves from the prison
that is the body otherwise all of this
is going to contaminate the soul and so
when the the season when the separation
occurs between the body of the soul the
soul is really just contaminated with
materiality it was not able to move on
to its it's a proper place which is the
real world of the forms the eternal the
unchanging the divine